reject nation John's favorite movie
company of all time next to anything
else that does independent films that's
not true how to talk to girls at parties
something John definitely doesn't need
help at because they just come up to him
and throw themselves at you this guy is
great at talking to girls Neverland
until I get in a relationship that's why
I gotta get in their relationship it
seems to be your style that's my style
oh my god she's taking interest don't
resent your relationship time hey stars
oh I remember those stars we'll find out
[Music]
Finity stones you shall all airfare
London
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
aliens
[Music]
but then they puzzle spanning some
bizarre sex rituals no how do you know
that
well just don't happen 24 hours to
rectify the situation you're in extreme
danger we gotta leave now
Wow Oh Kidman
[Music]
[Music]
damn John Cameron Mitchell back in the
game wasn't at all what I was expecting
that movie I thought it's gonna be
another one of those like a 24 and Robin
is about self conscious boy I mean I'm
sure it has elements yeah but it looks
like you know an 824 sci-fi yaki period
punk that looks cool dramedy thing that
looks really cool it's got the weird
hypnotic stuff that we like from
companies like a 24-9 if you're all that
I love the aesthetic of taking this
alien concept a more grounded approach
but still having a lot of it's weird
stuff it's weird hypnotic stuff I feel
like 70s aliens 70s exactly and you're
lending a name with like British rock
environment yeah yeah you know like the
punk scene combined with just LSD
because you know in the beginning of the
trailer you're thinking like oh they
just like tripping out right yeah oh no
this is probably real and this is
probably gonna get a lot weirder than
even what we're seeing here I would
imagine it took me a moment to catch on
that oh they're aliens the second elf
Fanning started to talk it was when she
was using the toilet and I was like oh
she's an alien but he said this is my
first time doing this oh okay see when
she cut her dress and she was like do
more Punk to me I was like oh yeah
you're not but yeah and I'm excited just
to see a new John Cameron Mitchell movie
because I mean Hedwig is terrific and
you know he doesn't seem to crank stuff
out at a time and to see him to
returning to something that's also music
oriented even if it's not a musical it
seems pretty cool yeah it's a cool spin
on those types of tales it seems like
the main dude is a little shy a little
self-conscious I just really like those
spins on those self-conscious boy
falling or a girl falling in love with
an alien that looks like a human and
learning about themselves and they're
also learning that society and there's
like a manatees yeah yeah
and all the connivance and the things we
could do better that seems like Nicole
Kidman is playing like the villainous
alien or something like that by putting
them on yeah I could see her being she's
good at those kind of yeah and to Zod
all pumped out after the aesthetic looks
cool the cinematography looks cool the
performances look great I've become a
big fan of Elle Fanning in the past year
yeah this looks like a really awesome
film unique a 24 but you expect from
these guys right yeah all right guys
well what do you think of this trailer
that really that's what you think you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
and click that notification bell to get
notified whenever a video of ours is up
and check us out a patreon full-length
TV show reactions for plenty of shows
over there weekly Q&A s would love to
have you become a patron eject